a deadly night on valley roadways as
officials continue to urge caution
during the labor day weekend thanks for
staying with us here at 6 30 i'm sasha
loftis three deadly crashes happened
saturday in just the span of a few hours
8 news now reporter orco mana has the
details for us the nevada office of
traffic safety has been trying to
encourage drivers and pedestrians to be
as safe as possible especially during
this holiday weekend but last night we
saw the 88th 89th and 90th traffic
related death in metro's jurisdiction
this year last night at around 8 45 p.m
a car hit a pedestrian on desert in near
mcleod police say a man was crossing the
street outside a marked crosswalk when
the driver hit him the pedestrian died
at the hospital and police say
impairment is not suspected a couple
hours earlier around 6 15 police say a
driver lost control near south durango
and badura the car hit a street lamppost
and overturned the driver died and
impairment is suspected in that case and
just before 4 p-m yesterday a
motorcyclist died after a collision with
the fedex truck near lake mead and
wynwood traffic safety officials tell me
they're frustrated but committed to
keeping everyone safe
as we you know continue with sunday and
monday
it's important that people understand
through education and enforcement we
intend to reach our goal of zero
fatalities every single day we are
stepping up enforcement today the rest
of today and tomorrow to try to be able
to achieve that goal while only one of
the three crashes saturday are suspected
to involve impairment the nevada office
of traffic safety tells me impaired
driving is still a major concern
especially for a holiday weekend that's
why the las vegas coalition for zero
fatalities is offering fifteen thousand
dollars in free lift ride credits for
new and existing users this labor day
weekend you can get ten dollars off one
lift ride with the code ridesmart ldw
and that offer is available now through
6 a.m monday reporting in las vegas orca
mana 8 news now